attorneys general from every state in
America are joining forces with major
phone companies to fight the rapidly
growing problem of robocalls an
estimated four point seven billion robo
calls were placed in July alone many of
those are from scammers consumer
investigative correspondent and a Werner
is here and what does this new agreement
mean for all of us
consumers well hopefully it will help
stop the calls right that's the idea
here you know consumers lose millions of
dollars each year to scam calls the
state attorneys general and twelve major
telephone companies say they've been
working for nearly two years to
implement a new voluntary nationwide
anti robo call agreement now the
companies say they will offer free call
blocking tools to customers that
includes blocking unwanted calls and
deploying a system that labels fake
calls they also agreed to dedicate
sufficient resources to investigate
suspicious calls and patterns which all
sounds good very good finally some
relief because I'm not even answering
the phone sometimes if I don't knows the
number I know so will everything be free
I know you meant to some of the public
call blocking services will be and when
can we see relief right so so they've
been calling for this this is this is
for free however not all the companies
are part of this the agreement does not
cover those who use old copper landline
phones there's no timeline for the 12
major companies to make good on these
voluntary promises this agreement
targets scam Robo callers so legal Robo
callers like debt collectors are still
allowed they can still call if there's
no timeline for this what do we do in
the meantime Anna yeah so that's a thing
so here are the tips okay first of all
don't engage with the Robo callers hang
up right away now of course you know we
all get calls I got one a couple weeks
ago and I thought this might be somebody
calling me I need to speak to you so I
answered it ever since then I'm getting
four calls a day because they know it's
a good number so please don't answer
don't trust your caller ID scammers can
make it look like the IRS the local
police station even a family member is
calling you know legitimate company or
government agency will ask you for money
or ask to be paid for a wire transfer or
gift card
yeah if it's a death they might ask you
for money but they're not gonna ask you
to pay with a wire transfer or a gift
card and by the way you can go into your
phone and block numbers if you're
getting repeated calls from those so you
know hopefully this will work to cut
this down all right all right Anna thank
you